for those of you guys that didn't grow
up with this I wish this could look more
appealing but I promise you it's
delicious all right what's up guys today
we are making Chinese steamed fish to
celebrate Chinese New Year aka Lunar New
Year I'm wearing red to celebrate the
auspiciousness of it all Chinese people
believe in good luck and fortune and all
that good stuff we're gonna play along
today I got a red tilapia fresh from the
grocery store so on top of being a
staple for most Chinese families eating
steamed fish is also very important for
Chinese New Year for people to bring in
some sort of luck I think and
phonetically I believe fish sounds like
some other words that means good luck or
something I just know that I like to eat
this and I'm gonna make it and only eat
it tonight when making Chinese game fish
it's very important to pick live fish
actually any time you eat fish if you
have an option to get them live get them
live because it's gonna taste so much
better the meats actually sweet won't
have that Odori flavor an easy way to
figure out if it's fresh is checking the
eyeballs if it's not fresh they'll have
milky foggy kind of look this is dark
and it's been tonight right here so very
very very fresh so a main ingredient
obviously this guy right here rectal at
the end now in western cooking we do a
lot of lemon juice that cook our fishes
with so that it eliminates that fishy
flavor right and Chinese cooking we use
ginger it also it has that strong acidic
flavor along with that is green onions
some soy sauce a little bit of oil done
super simple than one of the easiest
recipes that I know alright so let's get
started you got to have your fish clean
honestly the guy at the grocery store
did most of the work
sorry descale gutted and cleaned for me
so we'll just go ahead and put this on
over to the side and we'll bring in our
chopping board now is to prep our
aromatics
one two three four let's do about eight
coins ain't little medallions of ginger
cutting into little strips finder you
can cut your ginger the more aromatic
you'll be and it's gonna be able to
release more of its juices and more of
its aromas into the fish I like ginger I
don't think that's enough we're gonna go
for more that's twelve totaled next
green onions I got three stalks right
here get rid of the roots and cut this
in half and then I'm gonna section off
the thirds right back in alright so what
we're going to do now is take our ginger
that we just prepped and I'm going to
stuff a nice little pinch of it right
into the belly of it and then we're
going to take a nice pinch of green
onions we're gonna stuff this and do the
belly of it as well that way our fish is
nice and aromatic and then from here I'm
gonna sprinkle the rest of the remaining
ginger and that's all the prep work you
need so this is optional but you can
drizzle a little bit of sesame oil for
an extra dash of aroma and a dash of
rice wine now all this helps to cut that
fish smell now we're gonna set aside the
fish and bring in
this steamer now this is very useful
obviously when you're trying to steam
stuff we're gonna start from the bottom
the bottom level this is where you put
your water in very simple the next level
it's got holes in it this is where the
steam comes through to cook your food
this is where we're gonna be putting our
fish and lastly the lid now the steamer
is not just for cooking fish you can
also use this for dumplings steaming
eggs and custards vegetables crab we
could do anything with this but what if
you don't have a steamer and then always
not the steamer before I would always
use a wok and I would have this rack you
can find this at any Asian grocery store
but what I would do
let's take my wok let's water at the
bottom of the wok put this on top put
your plate of fish or dumplings or
whatever you're trying to steam on top
of it put the lid to the wok on top and
there you go makeshift steamer in fact
this is how my mom used to steam her
fish all the time
all right so now what you want to do is
fill up your steamer the bottle level
with about an inch the water
alright now once the water is boiling
take our fish place it inside alright
and now close the lid and really let
that steam for about 10 minutes
alright so now in the meantime we're
going to take our remaining green onions
that we didn't use and we're gonna just
julienne cut it into really really thin
strips this is gonna double as our
garnish and as more aromatics as we
plate our fish
now while the fish is steaming we have
our onions prepped we're going to make
our specialty fish sauce and you can
definitely use plain old soy sauce if
you like I like to jazz it up to make it
taste a little bit better dude three
tablespoons of soy sauce one tablespoon
of sugar and ironically enough half a
tablespoon of fish sauce go ahead and
give this a stir now we're just gonna
toast this sauce so we can get all the
flavors meshed together and it's gonna
complement that fish really really well
so next we're you're gonna want to do is
pour out all the excess fish liquid
because we're gonna replace that with
some jazz stuff soy sauce also we're
gonna remove the green onion from the
inside of the belly of the fish and we
replace it with the fresh green onions
that we've just
julienne I'm just going to heat up some
oil in a pan about two tablespoons
that's the oil is having an important
all over the fish we're gonna flash cook
all the fresh onions and lastly Brennan
drizzled the jazzed up soy sauce that we
made over the fish and voila we have
traditional bear bear traditional
Chinese steamed fish
[Music]
you